all right let's go next and talk to
let's go to chuck from pittsburgh chuck
you're on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
uh so i don't really have any questions
but i just kind of had some thoughts to
put out there um
one is like i we have like all these
people on the right that talk about like
their pro life and stuff
and i've never heard any like i wonder
what their views would be because i feel
like a lot of these people are also like
racist like what's their what's their
views on like
like racist pro-life because i feel like
a lot of these people like
don't like black people or jews and
you know like what would their
what do you think their views on that
would be
what what i don't even know what are
their views on racist pro-life what does
that mean
well so like a lot of uh i feel like a
lot of racists are also on the right and
a lot of like pro-life people are on the
right yeah um like
that that aren't for abortion so like
what would their thoughts be on like uh
a black person have an abortion like do
they even care or you know what i mean
well they claim to and then this is
actually something that the pro-life
right will use they'll say
abortion is incredibly racist because
look at the use of abortion by black
pregnant women and it's it's it's
particular so they whether they're
racist or not they pretend or claim to
be concerned about aborted black babies
as part of their anti-abortion stance
now you know whether they're genuine in
that concern or not is a totally
different question
they're basically just playing along to
act like they care about their their
views well i don't i don't want i can't
say act they claim to care i think is
the point and whether they do or don't i
don't know
yeah and then uh just another thing too
like i'm from pittsburgh to that bridge
that bridge collapse yeah i saw on
facebook a lot of people were like
commenting on the thing and a lot of
people are just complaining about like
you know we pay taxes and why wasn't
this taken care of and it's like
i feel like a lot of these people also
don't realize that like like i
understand the bridge was in poor
condition but like also like you could
just have like a a bridge that was in
great condition and accidents can happen
like
yeah statistically speaking i mean we
have sort of a normal distribution where
like for the most part if the bridges
are fine they're not going to collapse
every once in a while you get
bridges in terrible shape that don't
collapse and every once in a while you
get a bridge that's okay
as far as engineers are concerned and it
does collapse but correct me if i'm
wrong the bridge that collapsed did not
have a good uh structural rating did it
did it not
correct correct yeah it was in poor
condition yeah um i was just saying that
like i saw all these people commenting
about like you know i can't believe they
would let this happen and stuff and it's
like well
yeah it was in poor condition but like i
mean accidents can happen it could have
been in great condition and happened too
you know
and also there's dozens of i mean there
was a report there's like dozens or even
hundreds of bridges in new jersey with
the exact same condition and they'll
mostly be fine but this could happen
again at any time
yeah exactly but
yeah i mean i like i said i didn't
really have any questions uh been
watching since probably about the
beginning of the pandemic when everybody
kind of hyper
focused on uh politics yeah because of
all that so but yeah i'm a member like
the show and just keep up the good work
all right thanks chuck very much
appreciate it that's going to do it for
calls today we will take a quick break
and be back with much more and if you
didn't get on today there will be more
opportunities